the most complimentary thing you can say
about an actor is that he's versatile
but some Studios when they've got a
script that calls for a young actor to
an ardor an off that piece of playing
they sort of rack their brains and say
who can we borrow at paramount when they
get a script like that they say yeah
John can do it they mean John lund
I am here to present the award for sound
recording most people even those of us
who should know better think that sound
recording is accomplished by pressing a
button and then getting out of the way
it is in fact an extremely complicated
task calling for the coordination and
cooperation of a whole group of highly
trained men it is this for this reason
that the sound award is not given to an
individual the nominees for the best
achievement by a studio sound Department
are once more my darling
Neptune films Universal International
sands of Iwo Jima Republic and 12
o'clock high 20th Century Fox memo the
winner is 12 o'clock high twentieth
Century Fox
accept the award for sound according for
12 o'clock on this is also one of the
pictures up for the award
three previous Awards to sound
departments headed by him has mr. Thomas
Volker
thank you John
the award was accepted by Thomas Jamison
of 20th Century Fox sound Department